è da tutti ragazzi fermi nude vi sono
video sono fra vj ed oggi siamo in un
nuovo volo prima di cominciare come al
solito ripartire con la parata da
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da sara che ha fatto questo
disegno un po strano profico e direi di
passare ad un argomento strano come
molti di voi sanno io sono conosciuto
per il fatto che non mi cresce la
[ __ ] barba e questo da sempre non ho
mai mai
a me non è che la barba non cresce
semplicemente io da un paio d'anni a
questa parte tutte le mattine mi faccio
la barba cioè nel senso mi crescono
proprio quei micro peletti minuscoli che
non si vedono neanche a occhio nudo e io
tutte le mattine melileo allora ragazzi
ho voluto fare questo esperimento per
una [ __ ] settimana non mi sono
tagliato nei baffi nella barba io non ho
mai fatto questa cosa quindi non sapevo
cosa sarebbe successo se magari mi sarei
trasformato in gennaro gattuso o in
marco marino non potendo saperlo ho
deciso di provare è il risultato ragazzi
è stato questo fabio lovatti non me ne
roma ha colto primarie strano ma è
proprio c'è non vedo proprio ma ecco
onde evitare commenti del genere anima
stavi meglio prima state tranquilli
perché sta roba non dura più di cinque
minuti ho deciso di tenermi sta roba
fino a domani poi mi ha sporto la faccia
prima o poi nella vita dovevo fare
questa cosa
secondo che mi squilla il telefono
chiedevano se era cresciuta la barba
siamo arrivati a 3 milioni di iscritti
affaccia sul 1 grazie di chi dice che mi
mimì mi sono raccomandato dare un
[ __ ] però su questo argomento ci
hai qualcosa da dire prima dei 3 milioni
di iscritti è uscito un video di più di
pai dove dovreste fare attenzione ai
sottotitoli per un motivo in particolare
vi faccio vedere di costo parlando non
avete notato nulla di strano
rivediamo cosa per gene i sottotitoli di
un video di pd by apparso scritto follo
un fa vj sarà che fa vj e
veramente raccomandato da più di paia
non lo sapremo mai per quanto riguarda
le stranezze del web di questa settimana
direi che questo era solo la prima è
neanche la peggiore non so se vi
ricordate ragazzi immagina le storie
erotiche su di me non ve le ricordate
non andate a cercare un cazzo rimanete
nella vostra ignoranza vi sto per
mostrare altre due chicche che ho
trovato questa settimana sul web è sì
perché i bassotti di antonio banderas
stanno già facendo effetto leggiamo
insieme queste chicche siete deve essere
pronti però è perché non è una roba
leggera allora immagina se in casa somma
per questo è un livello di genialità che
rasenta l'incredibile 6 in casa sola
mentre guardi un video di favi j
ad un certo punto senti scassinare la
porta e ti vedi puntare la pistola
contro centrato un ladro mentre l'uomo
prende i soldi dal nulla fa vj sfonda la
finestra e ti porta via in braccio un
azione incredibilmente eroica e
complimenti fa vj arrivati nel bosco
inizia poi a spogliarti all'inizio
spogliarti to lori di 6sicuro l
sicurissimo
io sono sono commosso che che cazzo di
tramare sfondo st finestra prendo la
ragazzina poi sarà pure picco la prendo
la porto nel bosco e la forma di cos'è
che sei fumato prima di iscriversi cosa
ragazzi miei non è assolutamente finita
qua ce ne stanno al 32 che devo
assolutamente leggervi che fanno
ribrezzo via lorenzo siamo insieme per
fare una ricerca ma a me non piace tanto
l'argomento la riproduzione sessuale mi
vede preoccupate allora ti dice cosa hai
piccola guardare peter non guardarmi
cazzo sail piccola e io niente era i
verbi porca eva niente che io ti amo
perchè tu sei fa vj e io ti guardo
sempre sei proprio la mia donna te lo
giuro e lui allora vuoi provare a farlo
con me al santo di dio solo sa leggere
sta roba sta arrivando all fbi e io sì
certo
a quel punto lui mi prende mi sbatte sul
letto io comincio un orgasmo e penso che
lui
cosa l'ultimo e basta basta poi il
giorno ne pronuncia posso fare sei a
casa da sola che se guardando un video
di fa vj il tuo idolo quando a un certo
punto sentì suonare il campanello quando
vai ad aprire ti trovi davanti fa vj che
ti dice lo sai io ti ho sempre amata e
poi ti prende per i fianchi e ti porta
in camera da letto dove ti sfoglia e
inizia a farsi eccitare e dove tu perdi
la verginità polizia ed mi fate
cortesemente finire di registrare il
video pop line arrestate per due minuti
finisco giuro devo fare in fretta
ragazzi passiamo al prossimo punto c'era
una foto che mi ha mandato un ragazzo di
nome george ciao george e ti saluto ferì
non ha proprio io perdo le cose un
attimo c'è un ragazzo che mi ha inviato
questa foto mi ha detto come si cambia
negli anni e la foto è questa qua 2013
2014 2015 e il 2016 cesto cristiano si è
fatto tutte le fasi della mia vita
passando dalla marmotta all'anno
marmotta ti mancano i baffi prot altro
vedo che anche tu sei passato
dall'essere una ragazza al non esserlo
prova di sicuro so messo peggio io zio
erano l'altro inquietato ti ringrazio
per avermi andata grazie george che mi
seguì dal 2013 siamo ormai fratelli
entrambi non abbiamo problemi di capelli
quindi ragazzi miei in chiusura per
questo blog volevo fare una cosa in
particolare quando sono andato in spagna
ho giocato anche a pokemon gol tanto
troppo giocando ragazzi a pokemon glo
sono arrivato ad avere più di 400
caramelle magica questo ragazzi
significa che in questo preciso momento
posso fare evolvere magica e volevo
farlo in diretta perché è una cosa che
probabilmente poi avrò tanta [ __ ] tratto
sono uno al 154 robe del genere però mi
hanno consigliato di far evolvere questo
tratto 505 centro il toto caramel
quantica sono presi voglio far evolvere
questo a 132 perché quello al 154 a
delle statistiche che fanno un po cacare
ci siete ragazzi questo è il momento
della vita
chi è
vai vai vai forte vai perché non ti
butti in autostrada mentre c'è l'auto in
corsa ma forte ragazzi volevo fare
questa cosa perché siccome sono single
con questo con questa metodologia tutta
la [ __ ] sarà i miei piedi grazie grazie
mille vabbè ragazzi a parte le stronzate
e concludo che l'episodio spero che i
video vi sia piaciuto cosa è piaciuto su
un commento io mi piace anche a pagina
di facebook come di dottore descrizione
sono serviti di filati amici mi chiamano
prossimo video dei ragazzi tutto stop
porca eva mi chiama un telecomando è
ragazzi n'era dimenticato di dirvi una
cosa importante che ovviamente mi sono
dimenticato perché l'alzheimer ormai ha
fatto effetto tra l'altro mi ero
dimenticato di dirvi ragazzi che nel
diario mio questo questo qua ho fatto
inserire alcune mta fuoco testa di culo
grazie gentilissime pro fatto inserire
alcune delle vostre fanart tipo questa
che di valeria anche questa chemical e
superfiga queste qua che sono di sofia
ho fatto aggiungere le tra le più belle
in assoluto perché c'è alla fine volevo
che ci fosse anche un tocco vostro nel
diario in modo che fosse più nostro che
mi one ritirato dal punto di ringraziare
chi ha fatto queste fanart thank you
guys
guardi che cazzo di condizioni molto i
video computer e latte cereali col
cucchiaio ah beh io sto male
poi c'è uno nudo vabbè sentite e
scegliamo prossimo video bra ragazzi